in 1542 Spanish conquistador Francisco
de Orellana led an expedition into the
Amazon in search of a lost civilization
and its fabulous city of gold El Dorado
[Music]
eight months into the expedition half of
the original command to find El Dorado
was dead and the rest were starving and
dying from disease captain Ariana
volunteered to lead an advance party to
find food downriver
it was 600 miles downstream before they
found food
it took 14 days to get there and the
week but draggled men refused to row
back upstream to deliver food to their
command
so ariana made the historic decision to
continue down river where he calculated
they would eventually meet the Atlantic
Ocean the Spanish captain had no way of
knowing that it was around 3,000 miles
away but on their unplanned journey
Orellana claimed to have made one of the
greatest discoveries in history that the
Amazon was teaming with a sophisticated
civilization living in large walled
cities managing the jungle like a farm
we would never know the details of the
incredible story if it were not for the
writings of a Dominican priest father
Gaspar de Carvajal kept a journal as the
survivors drifted down the Amazon as
well as descriptions of battles there
are detailed passages of the people and
customs of a huge indigenous population
this is a temperate land and one of
great productiveness they are people of
very highly developed manners and
customs the priest
also records glimpses of even larger
civilizations inland
such large populations would have had to
produce a lot of food to sustain
themselves a feat that scientists in the
last century thought was impossible due
to the acidic soil but new science
indicates that the ancient Indians had
found a solution they were making their
own soil thus far is much better here
than the average soil that we find in
the Amazon in the reason why this floor
here is so good is because it's been
created by human action and at best
below the lush crops a thick blanket of
black fertile soil six feet deep covers
the entire site the vast interior of the
Amazon remained unexplored until quite
recently in 1925 British explorer
Colonel Percy Fawcett led an expedition
into an uncharted region of the
Brazilian Amazon to find what he called
the lost city of Z legends of lost
cities deep inland like those Orianna
had reported fascinated Percy Fawcett at
first there seemed little evidence of
the inland civilization that captain
Orellana glimpsed
but as the expedition continued further
into the jungle Fossett met tribes that
impressed him greatly he was fascinated
by their legends more clues that might
lead him to Z the last reports that
Fossett made suggested that the
expedition was not going well their
mules were starving
the Brazilian guides and native Porter's
had left
by the time Percy Fawcett arrived here
there was almost nothing left of the
ancient Indian cities the colonel had
little interest in native villages you
got mood does he live in LA but I didn't
either
did I metallic recruit the caliper lucky
Canella organism the other returning to
her where - to whom them have behaved
here bring up a bill in a pink una
laparotomy I co-taught eleven the mother
happy quaking young